This is a download from BBC Learning English.
To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Georgina.
Do you believe in ghosts, Georgina?
Well, I've never actually seen one, not even at Halloween.
How about dragons, then, or fairies and elves?
Have you been reading fantasy books, Neil? Lord of the Rings?
I have been reading a book, Georgina, but not Lord of the Rings.
My book is about an amphibious creature,
a creature that lives both on land and in water.
Some kind of frog, man?
Hmm, you've almost got the idea, Georgina, but think.
Woman, not man, and fish, not frog.
Half woman, half fish. Hmm, I've got it, a mermaid.
That's right. Mermaids are magical creatures,
half woman, half fish, that feature in the myths and legends of many cultures around the world.
Like the sirens, who's seductive singing, shipwrecked, or dizziness,
and his sailors in ancient Greek mythology.
The sirens are perhaps the most famous,
but certainly not the only mermaids we'll be hearing about.
But before we dive into the programme, it's time for my quiz question.
The book I've been reading was, of course, the little mermaid.
Yes, I've seen the Disney movie.
The mermaid is called Ariel.
Right, but the movie was based on a fairy tale written by Hans Christian Anderson.
It became so famous that a statue of the little mermaid was built in the harbor of Anderson's
birthplace, but where? Was it A, Amsterdam, B, Copenhagen, or C, Oslo?
I'm going to say B, Copenhagen.
Okay, Georgina, I'll tell you the answer later.
Disney's defenseless mermaid Ariel
seems the total opposite to the seductive dangerous sirens in the Odyssey.
In fact, descriptions and stories of mermaids have always changed from place to place.
One mermaid-like character found across Africa and the Americas is named Mamiwata.
Here's British writer Marcel Mateke talking about the origins of this legend
to BBC World Service programme, The Forum.
Even the name Mamiwata, which is pigeon English for mother water,
so it's loosely translated from pigeon English as the mother of water.
And the characteristics that I commonly shared when speaking about Mamiwata across the West
African coast is that this deity is the protector of the water kingdom.
The name Mamiwata comes from Nigerian pigeon English,
a language which has developed from a mixture of two languages and is used as a way of
communicating by people who do not speak each other's languages.
Marcel says that Mamiwata means the mother of water when loosely translated.
Translated in a way that carries over the basic ideas but using words which may not be so accurate.
Mamiwata is also described as the protector of the water kingdom and a deity,
a god, goddess or other divine being.
Another version of mermaid-like creatures called selkeys are found in the remote Orkney Islands
north of the Scottish mainland. The selkeys can take human form and marry men but every now and then
they return to their watery kingdom under the sea.
Christina Batillega is co-editor of the Penguin Book of Mermaids.
According to her, these different versions of Mermaids share something in common.
They force us to question our relationship to water and other beings in the natural world,
and even to question how we see ourselves.
Here's Christina explaining more in the BBC World Services, the forum.
The beings, not just mermaids but selkeys and water deities and other water spirits
are often shapeshifters. They have a certain kind of fluidity of being.
So do we approach this world with humility or do we really uphold a kind of anthropocentric
view, human-centered view of life?
Mythical creatures are often shape-shifters. They have the power to change into a different shape or
form. Moving between the sea and the earth, mermaid's link to natural worlds. Christina thinks
that as humans we should approach them with humility. Someone who has humility is not proud and
doesn't think they're better than others. Well, Neil, I don't think I'm better than a ghost,
a water spirit or a mermaid. It's just that I've never seen one, but then again I've never seen
electricity and I believe in that. Maybe it would help if you sought a statue of a mermaid if not
the real thing. Maybe, but where would I find one? In my quiz question, I asked you where you'd see
the statue of Hans Christian Anderson's Little Mermaid. What did you say, Georgina? I guessed
B. Copenhagen. Which was the correct answer? The Little Mermaid statue is found in Anderson's
birthplace of Copenhagen and it really is little only one and a quarter meters high.
In this programme, we've been talking about mermaids. Mythical half-woman, half-fish creatures which
are amphibious live both on land and in water. In some cultures, mermaids are deities or goddesses.
They can also be shape-shifters, imaginary creatures with the power to change into different shapes.
One African mermaid is called Mamiwata, in pigeon English. A mixture of English and local languages
which enables people who do not share a common language to communicate.
Mamiwata means mother water, but this is a loose translation. A translation which carries over
the basic idea, but using words which may not be so accurate. That's all for this programme,
but the next time you're near the sea, keep an eye out for a splash in the waves. You never know
what you might see. Join us again soon for more discussion and vocabulary here at 6 Minute
English and follow us on social media. Bye for now. Bye!